ONE BILLION. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO CALL OUR HEARING TO GET TO
ORDER IN THIS IS OUR FIRST.
BILL HEARING OF THE COMMITTEE
ON ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SHARON QUIRK
SILVA- OF THE COMMITTEE AND WE
WANT TO WELCOME OUR NEW VICE.
CHAIR AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE- SUZETTE GIRL THERE
IS TO ADD ALSO WELCOME BACK
MEMBERS RICHARD BLUM MR CHIU DR
CHOI MRS FRIEDMAN AND MISTER
NAZARIAN. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
THERE ARE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS. AND HERE WE GO DUE TO
THE CURRENT STATE AFTER AT HOME
ORDER FOR PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THIS ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAPITOL WE
HAVE LIMITED PHYSICAL SPACE SO
WE WILL BE. HEARING TESTIMONY
REMOTELY. TODAY A ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE CONDUCTING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. MASKS ARE REQUIRED AND
THE SPACE WE CAN ONLY CON
COMEDY EIGHT SEVEN MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT STAFF.
THERE'S ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANT DREAM PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYING FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN FEWER
CALLING MAN PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON. IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION TODAY WE ONLY HAVE
ONE BILL THAT WE WILL BE
HEARING. AND WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY WILL
NOW TAKE ATTENDANCE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE. WILLIAM HERE JUNE THIRD
JUNE HERE ALL RIGHT YEAH FOR
HERE. OKAY WE HAVE A FOUR
MEMBERS PRESENT AND WE WILL
BEGAN I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
ADOPT THE COMMITTEE RULES AS
THIS IS OUR FIRST MEETING OF
THE NEW LEGISLATIVE SESSION IS
OUR MOTION TO ADOPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE RULES. GOT A
MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
AND DAY SEPT SECOND BY VICE
CHAIR ROLE THERE IS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY- SILVA I WORK OF ART. FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MOON I
WOULDN'T MIND SHE HI. IF YOU
ARE CHOI ALL RIGHT TWENTY NINE
FRIEDMAN HI ALL RIGHT VERY. AND.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT FILE
ITEM AB FOUR SEVENTY TWO COOLEY
AN EQUITABLE PROCESS YOU PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND ALSO
FILE ITEM THREE AB SEVEN THIRTY
CORK SILVA ATHLETES AGENTS
MINOR ATHLETES HEALTH AND
SAFETY DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
GOT A MOTION TO. ADD A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR OVER. FIVE HI RIGHT
MMHM I DOING FINE SHE- ALL
RIGHT CHOI HI TROY HOW FRIEDMAN
HI REQUEST ALL RIGHT OKAY. OKAY
AND NEXT WE HAVE ONE BILL AND
THAT'S FIGHT OUT FILE ITEM TO
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS BILLS
AB FIFTEEN. PROVIDES GREATER
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR TICKET
BUYERS BY REQUIRING REFUNDS
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS TO
CANCELLATION OF AN EVENT AND I
REQUIRE NOTICE BEFORE PURCHASE
THE TICKET TO AN EVENT IS NON.
TRANSFERABLE TO A THIRD PARTY.
THAT COULD BE NINETY HAVE YOU
EVER RESULTED IN A MASSIVE
NUMBER OF ON. CANCELLATIONS
LIVE EVENTS PLEASE CANCEL.
MILITANT PROBLEMS FOR BOTH
TICKET BUYERS AND TICKET
SELLERS. TICKET SELLERS
ATTEMPTED TO OFFER SUBSIDIES
BERMAN SAYS THAT OF
REPROCESSING RESPONSE TO
CLOSURES. SOME COMPANIES ARE
FACING A LOT OF STRAIN FROM THE
AMOUNT OF REFUNDS. QUIETLY
AMENDED THEIR CUSTOMER
AGREEMENTS RETROACTIVELY TO
REMOVE THE REFUND GUARANTEES IN
FAVOUR OF SUBSTITUTE
PERFORMANCES. TICKET BUYERS
THAT ARE ALSO FACING A LOT OF
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS BECAUSE OF
COOPER NINETEEN AND MANY OF
THEM PREFERRED TO RECEIVE A
REFUND FOR THE SHOW THAT THEY
WERE PROMISED THAT THEY
COULDN'T GET INSTEAD OF A
SUBSTITUTION. PARTICULARLY FOR
SERVICES WHOSE POLICIES
EXPLICITLY INCLUDED THE
POSSIBILITY OF A REFUND WHEN
THE TICKET WAS PURCHASED. YEAH
THEY BOUGHT TICKETS IT SAID
THAT WOULD BE REFUNDABLE IF THE
IF THE EVENT WAS CANCELLED THE
EVENT GOT CANCELED NO REFUND.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY STATES
THAT A TICKET BUYER MAY REQUEST
A REFUND WHEN AN EVENT IS
CANCELED. HOWEVER CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT STATE WHAT A CUSTOMER
SHOULD RECEIVE THEIR MONEY BACK
FROM THE TICKET SELLER. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL ENSURE
THE TICKET BUYERS RECEIVE THEIR
REFUNDS WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
AN EVENT CANCELLATION WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH A- PROCESS
OF HAVING TO REQUEST ONE.THE
BILL ALSO MAKES ANOTHER
IMPROVEMENT TO THE LAW
GOVERNING THE SALE TICKETS IT
REQUIRES NOTIFICATION TO THE
TICKET BUYER BEFORE SALE IF A
TICKET IS NON TRANSFERABLE SO
THE PEOPLE KNOW THEY CAN'T JUST
GIVE IT TO A FRIEND. OR SELL
IT. WHEN PURCHASING A TICKET A
LOT OF BUYERS DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT THAT THEY PURCHASE IT
THEY CAN'T JUST GIVE IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE OR SELL IT- AND
THAT CAN LEAD TO HARDSHIP AND
THEY SHOULD KNOW THAT BEFORE
THEY PURCHASE A TICKET. NOT
MONTHS LATER WHEN THEY FIND OUT
THEY CAN'T AND THEY'RE BEING
TURNED AWAY FROM THE EVENT-
LIKE THE ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT
ONE SHOW IN LOS ANGELES IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THAT MORE THAT HAPPENED TO MANY
MANY PEOPLE. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS. WITH THIS BILL
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE AN AYE
VOTE TO THE WE CAN TAKE WORKING
ON IT THANK YOU. THE BILL. GOT
A MOTION. ON THE SECOND AN-
BEEF WE OPEN UP THE OR FOR
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
DO WE HAVE NY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. DOES NOT LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE ANY ROOM IT SO WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONES AT
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT
FOR FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX ON THE
PHONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ZERO. AND THEN- TO
THE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
BODY ON THE PHONES THAT ARE
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
ONE THAT'S QUEUING UP FOR
SUPPORT HERE JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THAT WILL COME FROM
LINE THIRTEEN HIS GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE THIRTEEN. AT
THE END OF THE CHAIRED ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE ONLINE.
YES. GO AHEAD MERICLE YES. HI
THIS IS A GREGORY HOLLAND UNDER
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
BROADWAY SAN FRANCISCO THE GOAL
TO GET ENOUGH OF HIM SHE EVER
AMBASSADOR THEATRE GROUP
COMPANY FIRST I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRPERSON TROUBLE FOR HAVING
US TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND HER OFFICE. FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ACCEPTING
LANGUAGE RELATIVE TO
SUBSCRIPTION ISSUE. I DO WHAT
THAT WE BROUGHT TO THE MOBILE I
DO WANT TO BRING UP AN
OUTSTANDING ISSUE AND THAT IS
REALLY THE TIMING OF THE REFUND
TO A CONSUMER. PERSONS BECOMING
TO INITIATE A REFUND FOR THE
CONSUMER. AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THERE ARE FOUR STEPS TO
REFUNDING MONEY ONCE AT AN
EVENT HAS BEEN CANCELED. WE'VE
THE TICKET SELLER INDUSTRY THE
REEF. BUT THEN THE FUNDS BINGO
FROM MOSCOW TO A MERCHANT
SERVICE PROVIDER THANK ELEVONS
WAR CHEST PAIN ATTACK WANTED
THEY'VE APPROVED IT IT DOES TO
YOU OFTEN A PAYMENT GATEWAY AND
PAY PAL THE FROM PAYPAL FINALLY
TO THE CONSUMERS BANK. AND THE
CONSUMERS BANK TO FIGHT TO WIN
THEY WILL ACTUALLY CREDIT THE
CONSUMER'S ACCOUNTS SO WE PUT
KLEINIAN LEGISLATION BASED ON
THE TICKET SELLERS ACTIONS IT
IGNORES THE FACT THAT WE ARE
ONLY THE FIRST STEP IN A FOUR
STEP PROCESS. AND WE HAVE NO WE
HAVE NO CAPABILITY OF
DETERMINING THE TIME IT TAKES
FOR FUNDS TO GET INTO A
CONSUMER'S ACCOUNT. WHAT
STRIKES ME WEDEMAN ANALYSIS OF
THIS LEGISLATION HOWEVER IS
THAT THERE IS A CONCERN AND I
DIDN'T KNOW PEOPLE THAT THAT'S
THAT TICKET SELLERS TICKET
SELLERS LIKE CUTS WERE ABLE TO
RETROACTIVELY. CHANGE THREE
FROM POLICIES AFTER THE TICKET
ALREADY PURCHASED TICKETS. I
DIDN'T KNOW YOU COULD DO THAT
AND I KNOW WE WANT TO DO THAT I
WONDER IF WE CAN FIX THAT.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
TIGHTENING. OVER THE RECEIPT OF
THE REFUND OR THE IMAGE.
INITIATE OF A- WE MIGHT DO IN
THE SELECT. WHERE DOES JUST
RETURN WHYNOW FOR A COMPANY
SUCH AS OURS THAT. AWAY FROM
PER. AND TRUMP IT WILL EVERY
TIME WE GET TO CHANGE. WE WILL
NO LONGER. SHOWS WE WILL CHECK
CANCEL FOLLOW THE FLEDGLING.
EVERY TIME CANCEL CHERYL FAIR
DISTORTIONS FROM ONE MONTH TO
SIX MONTHS. IT COST JOBS AT TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY UNION
PERSONNEL SO THAT. THE MESSAGE
BACK TO OUR UNION PARTNERS AN
IRP STATE CHAMPS WARDROBE
UNINSURED'S. BOX OFFICE. AND
YOU SEE WILL. WHENEVER A SHOW
TO CHANGED WILL CANCEL BUT
SHALL AND WE CAN TELL YOU THAT
THERE WILL BE REPLACEMENT WORK
IN THE FUTURE AGAIN I WANT TO
CLOSE BY THANKING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND OF SERVING
BROADWAY ACCESS COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH HER TO RESOLVE
GLOBAL MAIN CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
LINE JUST TO STATE IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED OR SUPPORT. AND AS A
REMINDER TO ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN CUBA COMES FROM
LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN- MY NAME IS
MARK A PREY ITEM THE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF. A E. G. AND THEIR
TICKETING SUBSIDIARY A ACCESS-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY WE WANT
TO THANK BOTH THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE AUTHOR AND THEIR STAFF
FOR- AMENDING THE BILLS SO THAT
WE TREAT. CANCELLATIONS
DIFFERENTLY FROM A RESCHEDULED
OR POSTPONED EVENT- WE ALSO- I
HAVE NOT GOTTEN COMPLETED THE-
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE NON
TRANSFERABLE NOTICE LANGUAGE-
IN PARTICULAR- HOW THAT
LANGUAGE OR HOW THE BILL- IS
AFFECTED BY THE UNDERLYING
STATUTE. THAT'S BEEN IN EFFECT
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS SO- WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THE
MEASURE AND HOW THE UNDERLYING
STATUTE MAY APPLY WE- WOULD ASK
THAT WE BE ALLOWED TO COME
BACK. TO BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE'S DOWN DOWN THE PATH.
TO RAISE ANY BJECTIONS THAT WE
MIGHT SEE IN IN THAT
APPLICATION AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR- BEING.
SO OPEN AND ENGAGING WITH US.
THANK YOU. HI WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENT TO SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF IT I WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ENGAGING WITH
THAT SOME OF MY THEATER
CONSTITUENTS AND SAN FRANCISCO
AND- APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE-
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS TO. ADDRESS
THE SUBSCRIPTION ISSUE AN
UNNAMED DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE STILL ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND- THE IDEA
THAT- THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
FOLKS- CAN INITIATE REFUNDS BUT
CAN'T ENSURE THAT THE MERCHANT
SERVICES ACTUALLY COMPLETE THEM
WITHIN THE PERIOD OF TIME SO.
MY HOPE IS THAT- BOTH SIDES
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT AND HOPEFULLY
RESOLVE THAT I KNOW ALSO THERE
BEEN SOME CONVERSATIONS AROUND
HOW YOU SUBSTITUTE IDENTICAL
SHOWS SO AGAIN MY HOPE IS. THAT
THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE- WITH OUR OUR
THEATER AND OTHER INDUSTRY
CONSTITUENTS ON THIS AND WORK
IT OUT BY THE TIME IT GETS TO
THE FLOOR AND IF I CAN BE OF
ANY ASSISTANCE- HAPPY TO DO SO.
THANK YOU AND ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. REMEMBER TO I IF YOU
ARE I THINK THIS IS SELF OF THE
CONSUMER ARE YOU APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL BUT- ARE ARE
YOU ACCEPTING TO- DOES SO-
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THAT A
YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY FOR- A HERE HERE THAT
THE THIRTY DAYS SO MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT TOO SHORT IF YOU CAN
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT THE-
LONGER AND THAT'S A ONE OFF
COMMON SOURCE ALL I HEARD- AND-
THE- SEPARATION OF A
CANCELLATION WHO'S GONNA
INITIATE. INITIATE THE MEANS
THAT SOMEBODY HAS CHANGED THEIR
MIND ON MYSELF I COULDN'T MAKE
IT BECAUSE OF A CANCELLATION
YOU KNOW FROM OUR ARMED OF FROM
DAY IT DEFENSE- A SPONSOR SO A
THERE MAY BE MANY REASONS SO-
WHY THE CANCELLATION MAY BE
NECESSARY SO IF THAT'S THE CASE
THAT THEY SHOULD BE- OAKS UP
DOUBLE- THAT- D. APPLIANCE YOU.
OR THE PROTECT THAT ESTARá SO
THE INDUSTRY WILL HAVE A FULL
FLEXIBLE. THANK YOU FOR THE I
ENDED TO CLEAR. THE CAN HERE IS
ONLY THE SHOW CANCELLATION NOT
IF A CONSUMER CUNCIL'S THEIR
TICKET WE'RE NOT THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THAT THIS IS ONLY IF THE
THEATER CANCELS THE SHOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONSUMER WHO BOUGHT THE TICKET
IS NOT PENALIZED FOR SOMETHING
THAT WAS NO FAULT OF THEIRS. SO
AS SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS PART
OF HOLLYWOOD- AND- CHUNK OF LOS
ANGELES- I HAVE A VERY THEATER
HEAVY DISTRICT MYSELF WITH A
LOT OF THEATERS AND THE LAST
THING WE WANT TO DO IS
CERTAINLY TO HURT OR PUT THESE
THEATERS IN JEOPARDY ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN SUFFERING SO
MUCH THROUGH QUOTED. SO IN THIS
CASE YOU HAVE AN AUTHOR WHO
WANTS TO PROTECT THE TICKET
GOERS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
PROTECT THE THEATRES SO WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. THAT DOESN'T-
PENALIZE THE GOOD ACTORS OUT
THERE THE SUBSCRIPTION MODEL
CANCELLATION WITH SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY HADN'T REALLY
OCCURRED TO US THAT THAT WOULD
BE A TRIGGERED BY THIS I IT
WASN'T OUR INTENTION TO HAVE A-
BEER COMPANY WHERE YOU
PURCHASED YOUR TICKETS FOR THE
WHOLE YEAR MAYBE THEY HAVE TO
SWAP ONE SHOW OUT FOR THE
OTHER. AND WILL ABSOLUTELY MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT- IS AFFECTED BY THIS SO
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
OF THE PARTIES- SO THAT IN THE
ND I DON'T HAVE ANY ANGRY
THEATER OPERATORS IN MY
DISTRICT AND HOPEFULLY NO MORE
VERY ANGRY CONSUMERS WHO END UP
GETTING STUCK WITH A TICKET FOR
A YEAR WITHOUT GETTING A
REFUND. I HAVE A JUST A FOLLOW
UP TO MORE QUESTIONS THE NUMBER.
ONE USE THAT- I- UNDER THAT
WOULD BE FUN POLICY WASHED
THERE ARE THERE WAS MUCH OF A
PROBLEM AND THAT THE- ARE YOU A
BEER SPECIFIES A DATE WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS. SO THAT IS-
KNOWLEDGE RESTRAINING AND
THROUGH THE- EVENT. OF HOLDERS.
YEAH AND THEN ALSO YOU WILL BE
OR IT GOES INTO EFFECT THE FROM
NEXT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
CORRECT SO IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN- I DON'T KNOW WITH THE-
CORPORATE NINETEEN. OH WAS SO
DRAMATIC- EXPERIENCE OF THAT.
STUFF OR SO MANY- EVENTS WERE
CANCER THE- HOPE WELL WE NOT
REPEAT SO I'M WHY THE THIS-
THE- ALL THE CANCELLATIONS-
THAT WERE MADE DUE TO.
CORPORATE NINETEEN HAVE BEEN OR
RESOLVE THE LAW ON RESULT IN
THERE WITH THE- DISCUSSION
SHOULD BE MADE TO
RETROACTIVELY. RESIDENTS IN THE
FUTURE NEXT YEAR ON- JUST
HOPING THAT THIS KIND OF A
MASSIVE A- CANCELLATION WOULD
NOT HAPPEN SO YOU'LL BE IT
WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE. IF YOU
TRY TO- ATTACKED CONSUMERS OF
WHAT VICTIMIZED AND THE-
INTENSELY. REFUNDS ONE ON MADE
YEAH WELL THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT IN THE
FOUGHT AYE I THINK PROBABLY THE
BEST WE CAN DO IS HOPE THAT. AS
THE BILL PASSES AND HOPEFULLY
WILL PASS THAT THE BIGGER
COMPANIES WILL START TO ISSUE
THE REFUNDS THAT RE IN ARREARS
AND THAT AT LEAST PEOPLE WILL
FEEL GOOD KNOWING THAT COME
JANUARY FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR.
BUT THERE'S HOPE FOR SOME OF
THEM AND IN TERMS OF WHETHER
THIS IS STILL A PROBLEM WE'VE
GONE TO WE HAVE A AN INTERN IN
OUR OFFICE WHO BASICALLY HAS
GONE THROUGH THE WEBSITES IN
THE PAGES OF A LOT OF THE
TICKET SELLERS AND THIS IS A
HUGE SOURCE OF CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE. THAT I'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND MONTHS TO GET REFUNDS AND
HAVE NOT GOTTEN REFUNDS FOR
SHOWS SO- THIS SEEMS TO BE A
BIG PROBLEM I COULDN'T TELL YOU
HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM IT WAS PRE
CODED BUT THERE WAS STILL SOME
ISSUE. AND THERE STILL HAVE
BEEN PROBLEMS IN THE PAST WITH
CANCELLATIONS FOR ALL MANNERS
OF THINGS- SO- I DO HOPE THAT
IT SENDS A SIGNAL TO THE TICKET
SELLERS THAT YOU KNOW THEY NEED
TO GET THEIR PROCESSES TOGETHER
TO START GETTING- TICKETS OUT
AND I AGREE WITH YOU I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE HAVE
LESS CANCELLATIONS AND THAT
OUR- THEATERS CAN GO BACK AND
HOPEFULLY THRIVE. PEOPLE WANT
TO GET OUT OF THEIR HOUSE AND
GET SOME ENTERTAINMENT. YEAH I
JUST HOPE THAT THE NORMAL OF
CONVENE NINETEEN KIND OF US
LAST YEAR'S KIND OF EXPERIENCE
TO WOULD BE AN OLD REPEATED UP
BUT IF AND WHEN. WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MASSIVE
CANCELLATION DUE TO SHUTDOWN OF
EVERYTHING SO IT'S PROBABLY
BEST A REASON- THE REFUND TO BE
MADE THAT THE MILLIONS OF
MILLIONS OF- OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE TO REASON- I THINK IF
CONCERNED THIRTY DAYS SO MAY BE
TOO SHORT OF TIME FOR THEM TO
PROCESS THAT AMOUNT OF- IN A
TICKET. THE REFERENCE. TO BE
MADE TO SO IF YOU CAN PLEASE
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS. AND THE
IMPACT SIDE I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FEASIBLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM. THANK YOU- I DON'T WANT
TO REPEAT THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MY FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WE'VE MADE A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS THAT I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE MADE- YOU'VE AGREED TO
KEEP WORKING ON THESE ISSUES
AND ASSIGN HAPPY TO. MOVE THIS
BILL ALONG. ALL RIGHT AND THEN-
VICE CHAIR FOLDER S. MOST OF MY
KIND OF MOST OF MY CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED- I WOULD
JUST SAY- JUST ASK RATHER YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SEEMS TO BE RECURRING IS THAT
THIS IS A MULTI STEP PROCESS-
CAN YOU JUST EXPRESSWAYS WAS A
SET TIME VERSES IN FORTY FIVE
DAYS ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME. AND THEN I WILL I'LL JUST
MENTION THAT I AM REALLY IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THE SHEL SHEER
VOLUME OF CANCELLATIONS THAT
HAD TO HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
COALBED I'M REALLY ARE IS WHY
WERE IN THIS SITUATION I
APPLAUD YOU FOR PROTECTING
CONSUMERS IT IS VITAL WHEN YOU
KNOW EVERY HOUSEHOLD IS LOOKING
FOR MORE MONEY AT THIS TIME- IT
IS VITAL OF THEIR- TICKET AND
HAS HAS BEEN CANCELED THAT THEY
GET THAT BACK INTO THEIR BANK
ACCOUNT BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS TO
KNOW WHY WE WOULDN'T MOVE FROM
FORTY FIVE DAYS VERSUS. THEIR
DIRECT WHAT WILL CERTAINLY
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
FEASIBLE WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS
JUST TO HAVE LANGUAGE THAT'S
VERY OPEN ENDED LIKE INITIATE
FOR INSTANCE AND THEN HAVE THE
SAME BAD ACTORS SAY BUT WE
INITIATED IT IT'S BEEN FOUR
MONTHS BUT IT'S NOT OUR PROBLEM
ANYMORE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS SOME SENSE THAT
YOU HAVE A CERTAIN THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE TAKEN SOMEONE'S MONEY.
AND NOW IT'S UP TO YOU TO GET
THE MONEY BACK TO THEM YOU
CAN'T JUST WASH YOUR HANDS OF
IT WALK AWAY AND SAY THAT IT'S
SOMEONE ELSE'S PROBLEM BUT WE
WILL WORK WITH THEM TO SAY WHAT
WE KNOW HOW REALLY CAN WE MAKE
THIS WORK HOW LONG THIS IS
REALLY TAKE- AND I AGREE THAT-
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY EXACERBATED
THIS BUT THESE WERE COMPLAINTS
THAT WERE COMING IN BEFORE
COLLUDED TO. YOU KNOW A ROCK
CONCERT GETS CANCELED BECAUSE
THE LEAD SINGER. LOSES THEIR
VOICE. AT THE SOMETIMES THESE
HAVE THESE BEEN PROP. IN THE-
AS WELL. SO BUT ABSOLUTELY. I
HAVE A LOT OF THEATERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT ANY OF THEM UPSET AT ME
EITHER. AND I ALSO DON'T WANT
TO HURT THEM. I WANT THEM TO
SUCCEED SO I THINK THAT WE WILL
FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
PROTECTIONS BUT WE DO SOMETHING
THAT'S- EVERYONE SAYS OH YEAH
WE CAN DO THAT. GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I ANY FINAL REMARKS
I JUST WOULD REQUEST REALLY
REQUEST THAT YOU ALL LET ME
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS WITH
EVERYBODY I THINK WE CAN GET TO
A SPOT WHERE YOU KNOW WHERE
THINK WE CAN MAKE THIS WORK.
THANK YOU. AND I TO SUPPORT AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX AS I KNOW THE
AUTHOR- WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH- THE- THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AND- FIND THE SPOT
WHERE THE CONSUMERS AND- THOSE
THAT ARE STAKEHOLDERS- WILL
FEEL THAT THIS IS A GOOD STEP
FORWARD- WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND WILL
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX FRIEDMAN TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. QUICK SILVA HI
QUICK SILVA HI RATHER THAN S.
HOLE. THE FIRM BLOOM FACT BLOOM
I TWO TWO I CHOI CHOI I
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I MOVED
THERE IN FIVE NAZARIAN HI. SIX
K. ALL RIGHT INTO OFFICE AND
THAT IS THE LAST OF THE
LEGISLATION WILL BE HEARING
TODAY AND SO I WILL BE A
JOURNEY IN OUR FORMAT. WE HOPE
WE HAVE A SERVICE. ELEMENT AND
CONTENT MISTER NAZARIAN. CAN
THINK CALENDAR YES. ALL RIGHT
NOW WE WILL BE ADJOURNING THE
HEARING ON WITH BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM IN INTERNET MEDIA
COMMITTEE I IS NOW COMPLETE AND
THE HEARING IS ADJOURNED. YEAH
AT. IT TAKES.